oh
dear I don't this looks like
[Music]
cartoonish are you doing so you
captioned this video what were they
thinking well here's my I love this guy
this guy is so funny what were you
thinking taking a video shaking your ass
in the bathroom at a Dolphins game
I was on a Dolphins game what what
[Music]
you what up guys welcome to the just
early things YouTube channel and welcome
to my reaction series before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today you want to be the
ultimate alpha male get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt the link is in
the description so today I going to be
reacting to attention seeking only fans
girl gets roasted by men let's
start okay I need to I need to First
prep it what what are these leggings
this color it's not your color sis I
need you to I'm not a fashionista all
right I need you to put that away this
is a bad BBL this does not this looks
weird it almost looks like a diaper I
mean
[Music]
I'm oh the poor woman is she's just
trying to live her life now she does
doesn't even know she's in she's in an O
Chicks
video oh dear looks like
[Music]
cartoonish the [__] are you doing so you
captioned this video what were they
thinking well here's my I love this guy
this guy is so funny question what were
you thinking taking a video shaking your
ass in the bathroom at a Dolphins game
just it was on a Dolphins game
intentionally get the reaction of others
and all for what for some likes and
attention on social media really and
I'll tell this guy is like the ultimate
women are ruining the gym guy he has
been on this for a couple years now
they're thinking they're thinking I
would love to go to the restroom in
peace without being recorded anybody
then get back to my seat and watch some
football and that poor woman in the back
that's just trying to do her job look
how visibly uncomfortable she is it
blows my mind what people will do and
how they'll disrespect others just to
get views on social media today you
should be banned from Dolphins games you
need to do better mind your own business
look at his
face no seriously chick put put the ass
and tits away it's time you know I have
been saying for a while now this is
getting sad I'm embarrassed this is
embarrassing A desperate plan to promote
heroni fans it's embarrassing and she
got flamed in the comments as well £200
a chew bubble gum probably thinking she
needs a diaper change is this actually
attractive cuz I feel like there's a
threshold she surpassed in the wrong
direction this level of narcissism and
self-importance is truly alarming when
you get a DIY BBL kit from Teo trying to
look sexy in a disgusting ass football
stadium bathroom is crazy how are they
not embarrassed doing this stuff in
public if I had a diaper that fo I'd be
mortified do this on your only fans
nobody wants to see you twerk in the
changing rooms get a grip yeah oh F put
that on your put that on your o and get
some Michael get some
[Music]
help what you what
you okay that is funny that is creative
oh I love good creativity I'm sick of
these
[__] [__] what they got going on in
societ huh he's sick with with I out the
Baptist
hospital I deem this inappropriate for a
wife and mother you guys were
wondering and I'm a CH C boy who
f
so you want a working woman would you
contribute to the housework if she's
contributing to the bills I didn't
necessarily say she have to contribute
to the bills she just has to work yeah
why I want to be able to build with my
partner I want to be able to say yo
let's do this or let's do that and not
everything have to be on me you know
what I'm saying you're the man
everything is supposed to be on you yeah
that's fine but then what if something
happens to me women are so lazy today
look I get some eat for my thoughts on
women working you know if you're going
to have one kid have one kid and put him
in public school you got seven hours a
day it's time to do something now if
you're like I was thinking what I would
do I was a housewife with one kid and my
kid was at I'd become like the best chef
ever you guys see me on this channel I
get I get obsessed with my hobbies you
know and but today women are so lazy
they're so they have so much free time
they do nothing with it injured and I
can't work I need better get up then
we're a partner we're a partnership
we're a team I need to be able to r on
you if yeah she will nurse you back to H
so you can get back to work the next day
so you're very modern anything can
happen in that time could be in 20 years
right and so this is what's happening
she wants the traditional outcome but
the men have adapted to the market and
they say [__] get to work I'm saying I
might be ill for a couple years you know
what I'm saying I need to rely on you
now oh God don't rely on me no I don't
want you to rely on me don't get ill
just stay working okay I'll see what I
can do thanks she's a lovely woman and
she'll make a great wife don't rely on
her don't get ill just go to work and if
you do get ill and you can't go to work
she'll probably leave you if you ever
feel bad about getting rejected remember
the time I told a guy I missed him and
he said you wouldn't miss me so much if
you had a full-time job he
C when I don't have to beg a man to
brush his teeth
anymore
wow who do y'all be
dating
oh that is so funny how much should a
guy earn for you to date him oh I've
reacted to this before deck please don't
do this over
500k you you make half a million a year
you like break you bust your ass to make
half a million a year and this is what
we get in return all right close to a
million if he doesn't I'm not going to
say yes do you hear me how much should
the guy pay for the engagement ring
he needs to pay again 500 are you
delusional do do you suffer from a
mental
illness said the food bill alone is
likely over 500k yeah that that might be
true sleeping at the club is crazy you
should already know she could get tragic
pic hop in the
beake up to wake up [__] get up oh what
is this for we about get into hold
on I got your phone I I don't care oh
you don't care no I don't have your
phone yeah I okay fine wait what don't
[__] stop stop she can check anything
other than Clash Royale that's is too
far let's not take the piss here can you
press buttons I'm scared of pressing any
buttons the last time I pushed the
button
nothing you said you'd prefer a guy who
does self-defense using other methods
are we talking like with his face not
like no what a oh I've seen this this
chick wants a guy that doesn't use a gun
imagine oh my gosh in England I always
say I would rather get shot than stabbed
so I don't understand why in England
they ban all the guns I'm like I would
pick one over the other I'll tell you
that that I just mean like I think a gun
is a bit extreme like if like cuz most
people would argue like for a legally
obtained firearm in like a circumstance
of self-defense like if someone breaks
into your home like like most people
would argue for that I'm just saying
like I personally would prefer a
different I don't know like there's five
home Invaders all of them don't have
weapons they're ready to throw down with
their fists against your husband would
you prefer he has his his hands or a gun
hands oh audacity don't want he's
getying
get what if what if after they kill him
they want to rape you wouldn't you want
him to have a gun in that instance whoa
I didn't know I didn't think they were
going to kill him well I mean they're
home Invaders if he's going to fight
just cuz you invade someone's home
doesn't mean you're just because you
invade someone's home that doesn't mean
you're going to kill it I'm I'm at a
loss for
words chance that could happen you donut
and if you think your boyfriend's got a
chance going up against five men on his
own and you're completely delusional I
don't think Jon Jones would be able to
fight off five men on his own I'm single
as hell I ain't got no boo No ba no
sneaking no nothing you smart where this
lady literally put the camera under the
stall I hope you got my good side at
least
huh wait oh it's the
same oh she was faking
it wow I hope you got my good side at
least
wow I was thinking that story doesn't
make sense why does so many women
complain that men don't show their
emotions because they don't show their
emotions a lot of the time you have to
guess what they're feeling where they
what they want from you and what they
want in their life they're not all that
upfront honest all the time I think
women want men to show their emotions
because I mean they're human and they
have emotions like it's a very normal
thing but society makes it seem super
crazy for a man to talk about anything
that shows like um how they feel which
is just so wrong please talk about your
emotions in reality they're not actually
looking for woman a man to show his
emotion so it it kind of goes like
they're double talking when it comes to
that I believe in my opinion I think the
women's feelings are always like looked
at as like more important a lot of men
don't want to share they also always
deem women's feelings as reasonable and
always deems men's feelings as
unreasonable so when you hear men
complain about women those feelings are
then deemed unreasonable but when women
complain about men their feelings are
reasonable emotions cuz they're scared
of getting judged by of a men and also
cuz they don't want a women to use it
against them how many women have said to
men oh yeah share your emotions be open
with them one way that women do this is
they start psychoanalyzing you and I
know cuz they do this [__] to me they're
like oh your childhood I'm like I had a
great childhood it was amazing I mean
and then they'll be like oh it was so
not amazing when the man actually does
it she uses it against him in the future
why are you still playing PlayStation at
this AG oh makes me it I can't let I
hear it like get a full-time job thank
you should if I was to be playing Sims
right
now if I was there doing
we you guys fake
life fake how does that make any sort of
sense so all of a sudden there's an age
limit for when you can you play game no
do you know what is that okay move for
an hour F who used to say that I can't I
can I can't be on my PlayStation for
more than an hour things to do you
should be yeah but what's women's screen
time tired sole I want to chill soep
some of the most successful people in
the world still play Playstation or Xbox
if you're a complete bum you're doing
nothing you're just sat on your ass
eating potato chips and you're only
gaming then yeah do something with
yourself but if you've got a life and
you want to do that to relax or as a
hobby I don't see what the problem is
also I'd like to hear them say that to a
game that's making millions a year or
ask them what their screen time is in my
20s I would not have thought that I
would be single in dating at 41 this is
the future you have all these ideas of
what is going to be you didn't planned
out the fairy tale
wedding in 10 20 years we'll live all
these only who is Brandy har is she
related to Lori Harvey is that like her
sister like Aunt maybe girl saying the
exact same
[Music]
words your girl says communication is
key but walks out of the car during an
argument yes you know all the women that
say communication is key are terrible
communicators literally
[Music]
terrible I mean it's goes right
communication is key but if she can't
practice what she preaches she belongs
to the
[Music]
streets that was funny I like this guy
he does a very he he picks reactions
very well and I like his edits that he
does guys let me know your favorite Tik
Tock in that series or clip and also
guys get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt really I I think we're seeing
men getting sick and tired of the women
on The Dating Market they're sick and
tired of these attention seeking women
that will seek attention to no end make
sure you guys like the video on your way
out and subscribe to the channel I'll
talk to you next time